[Música]
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña desde argentina josefina
martorell ella es economista también
máster en estudios internacionales y es
directora general de médicos sin
fronteras para américa del sur junto a
ella vamos a dialogar acerca del trabajo
que realiza la organización en esta
región por supuesto en tiempos de
pandemia josefina muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
bueno muchísimas gracias por
entrevistarme y dar lugar a la opinión
de médicos sin fronteras en esta
pandemia por favor es un placer tener tu
voz en nuestra pantalla josefina en
primer lugar qué acciones se están
desarrollando en américa del sur y
cuáles son sus principales
preocupaciones no en los países de la
región
bueno en américa del sur estamos estamos
trabajando en varios países donde en
algunos ya trabajábamos y en otros es la
primera oportunidad en los últimos años
que estamos teniendo intervención bueno
por la propia situación de la pandemia
del 19 entonces este podría decir que
estamos trabajando en brasil en méxico
también en ecuador que realmente hace
muchísimo no teníamos ningún ningún
programa también estamos seguimos
trabajando en colombia seguimos
trabajando en venezuela en haití en el
salvador en honduras en guatemala y
también bueno tenemos un proyecto que se
llama el padre que es el proyecto que
estamos que estamos interviniendo
digamos en diversos países a través de
una herramienta online de visitas a
distintos centros de salud a distintas
residencias de adultos mayores de manera
virtual así que también también nace
estamos haciendo una pequeña
intervención de sobre todo de
asesoramiento en argentina dando dando
también asistimos a asesoramiento en
uruguay así que te puedo decir bueno
perdón muy importante últimamente en el
en el amazonas peruano también estamos
estamos interés
viniendo por una situación de colapso
del sistema de salud y esto no quiero
relacionar sobre todo con lo que me
preguntaste de cuáles son los desafíos
principales que vemos y lo que estamos
viendo son son en casi toda la región
sobre todo en algunas zonas digamos los
colapsos de los sistemas de salud que en
algunos países ya eran eran frágiles
pero bueno con la situación del cómic 19
tal vez ante ante la abrumadora cremosa
crecida de casos es que se colapsan los
sistemas no solamente por los por los
casos del cómic 19 también por otras
enfermedades y eso es lo que lo que
estamos viendo con muchísima
preocupación en algunos países la
letalidad ésta está más controlada pero
pero bueno no podemos no podemos digamos
cantar victoria digamos y relajarnos hay
países que por la propia situación
económica no menos otra preocupación que
tenemos
de la informalidad de la mayoría de los
empleos en américa latina es que los
gobiernos deciden tener tener medidas de
escalamiento del confinamiento cuando
aún no hemos llegado en algunos países a
la salud al pico de los casos y esto
obviamente no nos preocupa porque porque
bueno puede haber una consecuencia
seguramente habrá una consecuencia sobre
sobre el sistema de salud que ya está
está realmente colapsado o al borde del
colapso claro esa es una situación que
sin duda se produce muchos muchísimos
países de américa latina con sus fines
imagino también limitaciones y
obstáculos no que imponen la pandemia y
sus restricciones en las tareas que
realizan médicos sin fronteras me
imagino todo lo que la parte de
logística de adquirir de transportar
medicamentos otros artículos traslados
incluso del personal todo esto en medio
de cierres fronterizos y demás medidas
que condicionan la movilidad no se les
ha hecho más difíciles sus tareas
sí sí bueno al principio ahora ahora el
tema del suministro del material de
protección personal ha mejorado en los
últimos meses y bueno y ya hay un poco
más de movilidad de llegada de ese
suministro pero si se nos está
dificultando muchísimo llegar a aquellos
proyectos o sea nosotros los proyectos
no solamente en américa latina sino
alrededor del mundo que hemos tenido
antes en más de 70 países más de 460
proyectos siguen existiendo y
relacionado también a conflictos y a
otras enfermedades más allá del coi 19 y
ahora nuestros trabajadores muchas veces
no pueden desplazarse hay proyectos que
no cuentan con el personal como para
seguir funcionando y bueno obviamente
eso eso es una preocupación en los
últimos pedirías semanas esto está
mejorando un poquito entonces estamos
pudiendo de alguna manera con viajes a
veces interminables de varios días y
que tal vez nos recuerdan a la primera
época de médicos sin fronteras hace casi
50 años desde varios aviones y después
un barco y después una camioneta para
llegar a algún proyecto porque bueno
obviamente
hay muchos muchos pasos que están
cerrados pero intentamos siempre llegar
hacia las personas más vulnerables que
realmente también también a nosotros nos
preocupa que el impacto digamos del cobi
19 parece que se está ensañando aún más
con las poblaciones más vulnerables del
mundo entre ellas se encuentran las más
de 70 millones de personas que se están
desplazadas con las cuales nosotras
nosotros y nosotras digamos desde la
organización trabajamos de manera muy
fuerte
una voz más ha manifestado su
preocupación ante lo que consideran
desde el organismo una falta de
coordinación internacional no considera
que estamos ante un escenario quizás por
llamarlo de alguna manera individualista
o nacionalista en el que cada país mira
hacia su interior y en ese sentido qué
mensajes tendrían no para los gobiernos
del mundo y en particular de américa
latina
si obviamente estamos viendo en el
último en el último tiempo varios varios
países que han tomado medidas digamos de
carácter populista y también también
nacionalista en pos de de tal vez ganar
una elección o quedar bien con su propio
país pero que no va en pos de la salud
pública global que es lo que nosotros
intentamos priorizar siempre y ante todo
ante una pandemia como como el commit 19
entonces desde la organización lo que lo
que estamos pidiendo y esto bueno se
relaciona se relaciona con varios temas
de la cooperación internacional en esto
de los suministros de los equipos de
protección personal también que bueno a
veces el personal de algún país hacia
los médicos o médicas o el personal
sanitario pueda desplazarse de un lugar
al otro
no con tantas restricciones pero también
lo que nos preocupa hoy y ya estamos
estamos previendo y estamos tomando
acciones por ello es el tema de los
tratamientos y la vacuna del cob y tizi
la vena entonces ya vimos y en relación
a lo que vos decías de estas medidas
nacionalistas
ya vimos que el presidente de eeuu
compró todas las dosis de los próximos
tres meses más o menos de decidir qué es
un tratamiento ante casi casos severos
de coronavirus si esto llega a pasar con
la vacuna que son los países más ricos
que puedan apropiarse de la vacuna y no
sea un tema equitativo globalmente
realmente la pandemia no va no va a
acabar
en el mundo digamos no no va a poder
acabar si no se acaban en todos los
países
joseba sobre esto particularmente quería
preguntarte no supongamos una vez que
estemos en el escenario en el que ya
esté la vacuna y que ya esté lista para
su producción no a nivel industrial su
distribución les preocupan el acceso en
las desigualdades en el acceso a esa
vacuna que pueda llegar a ver
totalmente esa es nuestra preocupación
el que la vacuna que puede llegar cuando
cuando exista tiene que ser accesible y
asequible entonces para eso tenemos que
exigir que las corporaciones
farmacéuticas no le pongan patentes o
sean o no pidan las patentes sino no
exijan esas esas patentes para la vacuna
y luego la puedan la puedan fabricar
digamos distintos laboratorios
fabricantes de genéricos para que haya
una disponibilidad mayor a nivel a nivel
global y por otro lado lo que lo que
exigimos y exigimos desde exigimos a
gabi que es la alianza de vacunas que
que trabaje con las corporaciones para
que éstas abran sus libros contables y
nos digan cuánto es que les sale
realmente producir y desarrollar la
vacuna del 19 y también los tratamientos
para que no lo cobren a precios
irrisorios y no tengan ganancias
desmedidas estamos exigiendo que las
vacunas del cobi 19 se vendan al costo
de producción más una ganancia marginal
pero que no sean ganancias comerciales
de las cuales se han aprovechado muchas
veces las farmacéuticas a lo largo de la
historia
saliendo un momento de la región no de
américa latina' en la pandemia presenta
un escenario inédito para médicos sin
fronteras y digo esto porque ahora
intervienen en algunos países en los que
jamás habían intervenido como por
ejemplo españa italia bélgica o francia
hablamos de países considerados entre
comillas países desarrollados no por
llamarlos de alguna manera que desafíos
representa esto para médicos sin
fronteras
bueno sí como lo decís la hora de
nuestra historia no nunca habíamos
intervenido en países digamos como en
varios países europeos que ahora en
cuando cuando empezó la pandemia
el epicentro grave es américa latina
pero fue lo fue en su momento europa es
que es que intervenimos en ese
continente intervenimos cuando cuando
vimos que había sistema de salud
colapsado nosotros realmente no venimos
a reemplazar a ningún gobierno y no es
lo que queremos hacer pero si nuestro
nuestra base de intervención es ver
cuando cuando existe una necesidad que
los estados no pueden cumplir porque
porque realmente no están colapsados o
en algunos lugares donde si
habitualmente trabajamos directamente
esos esos sistemas de salud no existen
entonces bueno los desafíos de trabajar
de trabajar en europa también
particularmente es trabajar en lugares
donde donde uno uno no está acostumbrado
y también la gente que trabaja en
general nuestros nuestros personal
internacional donde en su momento viaja
o yo he viajado a muchos países y nunca
me ha tocado tan de cerca y a veces es
difícil estar trabajando en su propio
país y ver el sufrimiento de nuestras de
nuestros familiares el sufrimiento
de nuestra sociedad tan de cerca que tal
vez no es la costumbre de nuestros
médicos y medicaciones y personal
internacional y obviamente hay un
desafío grande con el tema de la
política que nosotros más allá de que
somos una organización que somos somos
neutrales somos imparciales y bueno a
veces en estos países se mete un poco la
cola de la política y no queremos quedar
atrapados en eso y siempre priorizar
entre todos los países que trabajamos
siempre priorizamos trabajar con las
poblaciones más vulnerables entonces
trabajamos como las personas sin hogar
trabajamos con las residencias de
ancianos que bueno que en europa
realmente hay una mentalidad muy muy
grande después estamos trabajando
seguimos trabajando con migrantes y
siempre siempre bueno estamos trabajando
con poblaciones indígenas esto esto en
el amazonas entonces bueno en otros
lugares también pero me parece que es
importante que quede claro que médicos
sin fronteras intervienen con sistemas
de salud frágiles o colapsados y también
siempre focalizando sobre la población
más vulnerable
josefina martorel muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de france
24 ha sido un placer
muchísimas gracias a ustedes a nuestra
audiencia le invitamos como siempre a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com